hi I'm Erik Bosse back from the dead
vacation turns out that bright light
actually was hell and let's do a full
breakdown of all the interesting stuff I
noticed in spider-man homecoming
honestly I was just so giddy as a med
watching this movie that it was kind of
hard to remember oh right it's my job to
find all the Easter eggs that no one
else caught don't worry guys I got the
goods and if you haven't seen spider-man
homecoming yet those Goods might
actually ruin the movie for you
so spoilers people don't let this break
down do what Sony's trailers did and if
you don't want to get into all these
specific details just yet but you're
interested on a super interesting theory
on why this movie is so charming and
enjoyable definitely go check out Philip
Molina's review he goes into all that
stuff and yeah Philip his back and for
more details on that go check out our
channel announcement video okay let's
get started with the opening images this
movie opens on this kids drawing of the
Avengers in the Battle of New York all
the big names are there although the kid
drew Hawkeye kind of as an afterthought
in the corner also if you look closely
this sketch of the Leviathan coming
through the portal kind of looks like a
spider like a spider in the Avengers
shadow desperate to join them or even
get them to turn around and look at him
but I really like how this drawing
serves as a symbol for Peter's childhood
fantasy of wanting to be an Avenger and
it's that big boy dream that will
challenge Peters desires to stay as this
teenage hero with a relatively grounded
life but more on that later also
spider-man homecoming is the first
spider-man movie in the MCU and I love
how this movie totally embraces this
Marvel world like a kid playing with new
toys this opening scene takes place in
the direct aftermath of the Avengers in
New York's Grand Central Station the
same location where Hulk punched Thor
out of frame after tackling that
Leviathan in fact I'm assuming that's
the same Leviathan that we see in the
scene now tombs as crew gets halted by
the do DC Department of damage control
led by this woman anne-marie Hogue now
Hogg and damage control are from the
Marvel Comics it was a spin-off series
about the team who cleaned up after all
the big superhero battles Marvel
actually had plans to develop damage
control as a TV series on ABC before it
ended up getting canceled okay so then
the movie jumps forward to eight years
later and all of us nerds him the
audience began to malfunction okay so
here's the confusion with this up until
this point the marvel timeline has been
pretty straight forward more or less
following our real-world timeline so
like the first Ironman is set in 2010
and the events of Incredible Hulk and
Thor and Captain America First Avenger
and Ironman
- all take place around the same time in
2011 until Avengers which is set in 2012
and that is presumably where this scene
with tooms takes place the problem is
the rest of this movie takes place
during or two months after Captain
America Civil War which we were pretty
sure was set in 2016 which is four years
after the Avengers not eight years later
by the way the way we know all these
dates is from specific little Easter
eggs in each of these movies like an
Iron Man 3 we know it was Christmas 2012
from the opening new year's flashback
and then in Thor the dark world there's
a calendar in the background with
November 2013 also there's a show agents
of shield that references events in the
movies as they happen which pretty much
reinforces this timeline so why does the
movie change the timeline like this
moving it forward eight years after
Avengers when it's clearly impossible if
it's also taking place right after Civil
War now I would say none of this matters
maybe we're just nerves being too nit
picky with the details but come on
this is Marvel the home of nerds John
wants actually confirmed that Marvel
does have a super detailed timeline
scroll for all MCU events going back to
the dawn of time so I'm assuming that
this wasn't an accident
and Feige did this for a reason and I
have two theories on this my first
thought is that this is dr. Strange's
fault remember that movie ended was
strange using the time stone in the eye
of agamotto to create a loop in time
rewinding over and over again to
eventually defeat Dormammu so maybe that
meddling caused a rift in time pushing
everything for years later than it
should be kind of like when you're
streaming something and you keep trying
to hop back ten seconds then randomly it
just jumps forward ten minutes later and
spoils the ending for you oh god no no I
regret meddling okay you're right I know
this theory sounds a little nuts but if
this is true the reason could be that
the upcoming infinity war movies will be
so catastrophic and so insane
that dr. strange will need to use the
time stone again to reset the time line
back before civil war to prevent the
Avengers in fighting so that they can
take on Thanos and a more unified front
and that Medellin will fix the time line
and close this eight-year gap to reset
it back to normal huh don't you look
time travel confusion is fun anyway I
have another less bonkers theory for
this timeline jump that I'll get to in a
bit but first let's talk about Adrian
Toomes the vulture as a villain I loved
Michael Keaton's adaptation of this guy
he's the first blue-collar self-made man
to appear as a villain in the MCU unlike
all the other titans of industry and
demigods and living planets he's
small-scale in DIY which makes him a lot
like Peter actually Phillip does go
super in-depth into this whole
small-scale approach and spider-man
homecoming in his review that you should
definitely watch it's really the whole
secret of this movie's success in my
opinion now the other Marvel character
featured prominently in these opening
scenes is Phineas Mason aka the tinkerer
from the Marvel comics now like he does
in this movie the tinkerer gathers old
scraps to make new weaponry for a lot of
Marvel characters looting Mysterio a
member of the sinister six who we might
see in an upcoming movie but Phillip
actually did a post-credits scene
breakdown in another video that you
should go check out for more details on
that okay moving on to this Marvel
fanfare and the music here was composed
by Michael Giacchino
this guy's done a ton of stuff he
actually composed the score recently for
Doctor Strange and you probably knows
hear how he sampled the 60s spider-man
theme into the music but we actually
just heard a more subtle choice that
chiquinho made the way that he came up
with vultures theme music now you can
actually hear this on the homecoming
soundtrack and the track called the
world is changing takeno starts with the
classic Avengers theme which we actually
heard on that opening shot of the
Avengers tower but then later after
tooms says the line world's changing
boys it's time we changed to the
Avengers core twists from a major chord
down to a minor chord and it gives us
this darker more sinister vulture theme
so just like how tooms is repurposing
the Avengers weaponry intact for his own
sinister goals chiquinho is repurposing
the Avengers music for his he
desires yeah we see you chiquinho all
right moving on to Peter's home video
footage showing us his side of the Civil
War event and if you look closely the
beginning of a there's a quick shot of
the Unisphere from the World Fair in
Queens now this globe was seen an Iron
Man 2 when stark saves a little boy
wearing an Iron Man mask and actually
according to Tom Holland Kevin Feige
decided to retcon this little boy as
young Peter Parker so really Peters been
part of the MCU as a young of interest
fan for a long time and this is the
other slightly more rational theory on
why the movie jumps forward eight years
so Peter Parker is supposed to be 15
years old and homecoming but if the old
MCU timeline is true and Iron Man 2
takes place only four to five years
before homecoming that would mean this
kid in the shot is only 10 to 11 years
old and to me he looks way younger maybe
like five or six so it could be just
that eight year time jump was Feige
going back to make that easter egg make
a bit more sense like homecoming would
need to be nine or so years after Iron
Man 2 or 8 years after Avengers for this
little kid to grow up enough to become
Tom Holland and maybe you just hope none
of us would care this much now of course
pushing everything back like that also
seems a little crazy in another way like
it would mean there would be a five-year
gap after Avengers or really nothing
happened in the MCU until Winter Soldier
arrives and then we'd have to ignore
everything and agents of shield and we
shouldn't it's a it's a good show it got
really good so either they jumped eight
years to let this kid grow up and make
this minor Easter Egg work or they're
sending up a crazy Doctor Strange
time-travel reset and infinity wars or
some other reason that none of us are
seeing anyway let me know what you think
about this timeline stuff in the
comments and real quick two little
things to point out about Peters videos
I like how when he gets his new stark
design suit he says look at the eyes
which I feel like is a meta joke about
our reaction when we first saw
spider-man back in that civil war
trailer only look at my mass also Peter
does this back flip to talk to happy and
I'm pretty sure that was a real back
flip performed by Tom Holland like
apparently this kid is super agile and
John Watson said that he is in a lot of
ways a real-life spider-man
okay moving on past the scene with Stark
that we saw a lot in the trailers to
Peter's High School which is full of
little winks and references to the
Marvel Comics first there's Flash
Thompson
Peter Parker's longtime bully played by
Tony River Lori and I Myka this movie
changes him from the stereotypical brute
who's probably in his 30s to someone who
actually looks like a kid who bullied
you in high school like he's also kind
of a nerd he's just confident then in
this hilariously poorly produced morning
news there's Betty Brant in the comics
Betty Brant works at the Daily Bugle a
parker posey actually played her in the
Sam Raimi movies and her co-host is less
noticeable but that's Jason E&L oh he's
one of flash Thompson's buddies in the
comics now Peters best friend is Ned
Leeds who in the comments is a bugle
reporter and Betty Brandt's husband he
later gets brainwashed to become a
version of Hobgoblin but really this
character has a lot more in common with
Genki Lee who is the Miles Morales
spider-man's best friend in the ultimate
comics his whole book and his sense of
humor and the fact that he knows
spider-man's secret yeah clearly this
version of the character is pulling a
lot more from the ultimate comics and
then of course there's this movies love
interest
Liz Allen who actually predates Mary
Jane Watson and Gwen Stacy in the comics
we also already saw a version of Alice
Allen in the first Sam Raimi spider-man
movies she's the nerdy girl who says
seats taken to Peter on the bus and then
later we see that girls Cindy on Peters
Academic Decathlon team that is Cindy
moon aka silk from the spider-man comics
but my favorite character reference in
the school is principal Morita played by
Kenneth Choi he also played Jim Morita
the howling commando from Captain
America the First Avenger and this
principal is this guy's grandson he
actually keeps an old army photo of his
grandfather in his office which we see
later in the movie and of course if you
look in the background at the school
there are images of Howard Stark also a
picture of Bruce Banner in Peters
classroom there's also apparently a
picture of Abraham Erskine somewhere but
I couldn't find him but check out that
business problem on the dry erase board
that Peter answers now the reason he's
able to get it so easily without paying
attention at all is because it's about
the motion of a pendulum which is the
same kind of mental math and physics
that Peter does anytime he swings from
his web and later Peter answers a trivia
question on the bus where the answer is
strontium barium and vibranium course
vibranium is the metal and cap shield
and the metal weave that forms black
panther's suit it'd be funny of all of
peter's intelligence just based on
superhero related facts so class who
wrote The Canterbury Tales Peter Hulk we
also see Peter make his own
wedding which he calls web fluid version
3.0 one which someone said might be a
reference to the fact that this is the
third version of spider-man and his
webbing that we've seen in the movie now
I just love the choice to depict Peter
Parker as this impatient teen staring at
the clock all day as he waits to run
home and play around with his suit in
fact this long awkward take of him
clumsily changing into the suit in the
alley is something that all the other
spider-man movies have skipped over but
I think it's important for the tone of
this film like Peter is an awkward kid
and he's genuinely stoked to be
spider-man even if none of these other
New Yorkers really care about that but
two guys who do care are these two
they're the ones who asked spider-man to
do a flip this older guy holding the
boombox is named Kirk Thatcher and I'm
assuming you don't recognize him but way
back in the 80s he played another Punk
with the boombox in the movie Star Trek
for the voyage home and yes that's Kirk
and Spock on an 80s subway train Kevin
pike is actually a big fan of the movie
and he asked Thatcher if he wanted to
make a cameo in spider-man homecoming
and then after the Stan Lee cameo where
he yells at Peter for setting off a car
alarm we get this ATM robbery scene now
the criminals wearing these Avengers
masks could be a reference to a similar
scene The Ultimate Comics but that one
had a Batman mask or because this is
Marvel it is an unknown black mask with
pointy ears like who is this character
he's from a different universe also
notice how Peter says Thor Hulk nice to
finally meet you and yeah that's because
the were and Hulk weren't in that
airport battle in Civil War but when
this fight results in the Bodega getting
blown up
we specifically see Peter save a cat
which of course is a little nod to the
famous screenwriting adage that says
heroes should do a small missable act of
kindness also known as save the cat
early on at some point the story that's
why a lot of times the movies you'll
just see heroes randomly saving cats as
kind of a in joke to that then Peter
returns to his bedroom where we get a
bunch of little visual references to
Star Wars with Peters 8080 which is a
reference to Peters line in Civil War
there are also a bunch of figurines on
the shelf
and Ned's Lego Death Star so yeah one
benefit of Disney owning both Marvel and
Star Wars is that spider-man gets to be
as much of us our wars obsessed nerd as
we were in high school
poor long after high school and then
when Ned geeks out over Peter Bean
spider-man some of his dumb questions
actually reference things from
spider-man history like he asks if he
can spit venom which feels like a
reference to Venom's upcoming solo film
he also asks if he can summon an army of
spiders which Peter kind of does with
robotic spiders at some point in the
comics net also might be referencing
ant-man who kind of summon an army of
ants now if you were wondering Peter
does possess spidey sense in this movie
even though we don't really see him use
it John wants just chose not to focus on
it so much because all the previous
spider-man films leaned on it a lot and
then there's this moment when Ned says
that if he was him he'd stand on top of
a building and shoot his webbing as far
as he could which we saw Tobey Maguire's
spider-man do in that first movie now if
you were listening closely during this
their teacher actually mentions the
sokovia accords remember that was the
international treaty that caused the
rift between cap and Stark and Civil War
this is just another example of
homecoming grounding Peter as this
street-level hero in this Marvel
Universe with a detail that probably
yeah would come up in a history or
civics class but my personal favorite
example of this in the movie is of
course Captain America's motivational
videos which we see throughout the movie
now I don't know if kids are still
watching these in school but when I was
a kid they showed us these goofy
celebrity testimonials all the time like
why is Michael Jordan talking to us
about drugs and the gym coach he's
played by Hannibal Buress points out
that cap is considered a war criminal
but that he still is to show them these
videos anyway and yeah if you think
about it you can imagine how principal
Morita would still support his war hero
grandfather's old buddy and really how
the whole state of New York would still
celebrate its hometown hero now in the
background you can see Michelle's and I
as character reading of Human Bondage
that's a book written by W Somerset mom
about being a slave to one's emotions
and desires and this is very on game for
Michelle she's the definition of
emotionally detached I also like how you
can see her bench pressing the book
while she reads it later also later in
the movie on the bus Michelle reads
invitation to a beheading by flat Amir
double coffee it's an existential novel
about a man being imprisoned for his
inability to fit in with other people in
society which yeah another classic loner
read now I really
this detail of the girls playing fmk
with the Avengers and Betty said she
wanted to eff Thor marry Iron Man and
kill Hulk and yeah how do you think
about it I guess it makes sense that
these New York kids would hate Hulk more
than the others especially if they lived
in Harlem there's a very good chance
Hulk smashed one of their houses okay
moving on to Liz's party and this movie
does such a good job capturing the feel
of being a teenager with your first
house party feeling thanked the event
that will change your life so yeah
definitely wear that hat and then later
when Peter sees Bryce showing Aaron this
explosive weapon Bryce mentions how it
was an arm from an Ultron minion in
sokovia he also mentions the black hole
grenades which were featured in Thor the
dark world and then really cool this
shocker weapon was actually modified by
Mason from crossbones gauntlet which we
saw a cap knock off his arm back in
Civil War seriously I think everything
in this movie is recycled from some
other Marvel film it's very
environmentally friendly and then when
Peter runs through the back yards to
chase the van some of us might have
already felt this was a little familiar
but before we could place it the movie
actually doesn't for us cutting into a
scene from Ferris Bueller's Day Off when
Ferris rushes home playing on a TV
screen so Ferris Bueller's Day Off and a
lot of the other 80s teen comedies were
directed by John Hughes and his movies
were a big influence on spider-man
homecoming that was apparently Kevin
Feige x' idea and he actually brought on
the vacation directors John Francis
daley and Jonathan M Goldstein as ho
writers on this script to bring that
Hughes style comedy into it Don watt
said that something about those teen
movies feel like high school for all of
us like even if you weren't from Chicago
when you think about high school you
think about a high school in Chicago
thanks to John Hughes films Tom Holland
actually said that Watts gave the cast a
list of these Hughes movies to watch
including Ferris Bueller and The
Breakfast Club which definitely seems to
inspire the scene with Peter in
detention that scene also had Michelle
as the loner girl who doesn't even have
to be in detention which is a reference
to a leash Edie's character in The
Breakfast Club you want to know what I
did to get in here nothing I didn't have
anything better to do okay so then when
tooms snatches spider-man listen closely
to the sound that he makes so the sound
editors actually mixed in the CAW of a
real-life vulture here and really when
you think about it the character the
vulture really
is vulture like like he scavenges old
tech and vultures as birds are natural
scavengers okay moving on Peter and Ned
hacked into Starks suit to disable its
training wheels protocol and open up all
of its functions and this could be
inspired by that moment in the civil war
comics winds start give spider-man this
new iron spider armor and then Peter
later hacks into the armor to rig it the
way he wants now I have more on that
iron spider armor a bit later now the
voice of the suit lady AI Karen is
actress Jennifer Connelly she played
Betty Rosson and Lee's Hulk but also
she's married in real life to Paul
Bettany who plays vision and before that
the voice of Jarvis Tony Stark's AI so
way to keep the AI in the family Tony
now there are a few more Easter eggs
here
Spider Man actually hears tunes guys
talking about the Triskelion mess which
is a reference to the helicarrier's in
DC in Winter Soldier they also mentioned
the Lagos incident which is the Nigerian
city at the beginning of civil war and
then when Spiderman gets trapped in the
do DC storage he finds in tombs bag and
old stark arc reactor and the severed
head of an Ultron minion so the decision
to place his sequence in Washington DC
said of some nice throwback moments with
Peter running past the Lincoln Memorial
reflection pool just like Sam and cap do
and when her soldiers also the
Washington Monument as a landmark could
be a reference to spider-man's battle
with titanium man in the road to civil
war comics and even though this moment
of spider-man shooting is webbing to
save Liz from falling felt like it might
have been a gwen stacy an amazing
spider-man 2 moment but then I really
enjoyed this twist to a different love
interest with Karen tallian Peter to
kiss Liz upside down like the iconic MJ
kiss in the first spider-man but of
course it doesn't go that way let's move
on to this scene with donald Glover's
character now in the Ultimate Comics
Aaron is the Prowler the uncle to Miles
Morales and this scene confirms that
when Aaron mentions having a nephew
which firmly establishes Miles Morales
in the MCU and in case you didn't catch
it there's an even more subtle easter
egg here herrings license plate reads
UCS mo1 which I'm pretty sure stands for
Ultimate Comics spider-man issue oh one
which was Miles Morales debut so even
though Glover won't get to play Morales
like he did when he voiced a character
in the animated series at least he's
playing some role in bringing the care
the screen okay moving on to the ferry
which we already saw a lot of in the
trailers but one new thing to point out
is this guy Mac Gargan played by Michael
mando for better call Saul on his neck
as a tattoo of a scorpion and that's
because in the comics Mac Gargan is the
Scorpion one of spider-man's well-known
villains actually in other versions of
the comics Gargan becomes a super
violent version of venom when the sybian
attaches itself to him so this sequence
ends with stark taking back the suit
giving Peter this lecture if you're
nothing about this shoot then you
shouldn't have it this whole idea I'm
pretty sure is a callback to the debate
between stark and cat back in the
Avengers big man in a suit of armor take
that off what are you genius billionaire
playboy philanthropist see stark
understands that the suit doesn't make
the man and for Peter this is a critical
step for his growth as a character just
like Thor having to get his hammer back
Peter has to earn the tool by proving
his worth as a hero underneath and this
leads to a really fun shift as we see
Peter putting on a different suit the
clothes of a normal teenager as Aunt May
helps him get ready for the homecoming
dance
actually feel like Peter's slide in the
frame in the scene might have been a
reference to Tom Cruise and risky
business which could have been another
one of those 80s teen comedies that Tom
Holland had to watch okay moving on to
this big twist that tombs is Liz's
father creating his perfect blend of the
two most tense situations a guy picking
up his date and talking to the dad who
clearly hates him and in a superhero
movie the hero and villain coming face
to face now tombs holds a butcher knife
in the scene which feels like a
reference to Norman Osborn carving the
turkey in the first spider-man which
also had that same nerve-racking and
dramatic irony now when they're in the
car there's an interesting lighting
choices going on here notice how there's
this red demonic light glowing on tubes
of space from the stop light as he
starts to figure out who Peter is and
then after a moment the light switches
to green which in a way is even more
menacing that's the color of tombs is
vulture helmet and the green light
signals that in this moment he has
transformed from slightly intimidating
dad to murderous supervillain the
vulture the prevalence of the color
green is actually very common in these
first installments of the spider-man
movies like Sam Raimi actually used the
color green often to associate with
Green Goblin also Green was the color of
dr. Connors the lizard in the amazing
spider-man okay moving on Peter goes
inside to say goodbye to Liz and you
might have noticed that he doesn't lean
in to kiss her unlike what we saw in the
trailer actually John Watts said that he
included a few shots that were just for
the trailers including the kiss shot and
this shot of spider-man and Iron Man
swooping in together as well as this
test footage of the vulture and while
using these alternate shots that are
only in the trailers makes my job as a
trailer breaker down or a bit harder as
a fan I kind of love this like all I
really want for trailers is to give me a
sense of what kind of movie this is
gonna be and not spoil exactly how the
story will go down either way just make
sure what's in the actual movie is
better than what's in the trailer like I
will admit it would have been nice to
see Iron Man and spider-man flying in
formation well there's always infinity
war okay moving on to a few more Easter
eggs Peter does his best Christian Bale
Batman voice to intimidate flashed into
handing over his car
and yeah I kind of feel like taking a
dad sports car for a joyride and end up
wrecking it is another detail pulled
from Ferris Bueller's Day Off actually
seconds earlier flash mentions to his
date that the branzino wasn't fresh
which could also be a reference to the
amazing spider-man remember Gwen Stacy's
mom made branzino when Peter went over
for dinner shortly after the scene we
hear happy say that the inventory on the
plane includes Starks Hulkbuster armor
which we saw an age of Ultron and then a
prototype for Cap's news shield probably
to replace the damaged one at Civil War
and then Thor's magic belts now happy
couldn't pronounce it but it's called
Megan jor oh I think I got that right
anyway it enhances Thor's strength now
my favorite joke in the movie was Ned
telling the teacher in the computer lab
that he was looking at porn which is
also one of my favorite gags from Rick
and Morty mr. Smith
oh yeah just masturbating but the most
heart-wrenching moment of the movie
comes when Peter is trapped under the
rubble
he feels like such a real kid in this
moment crying out for help like you can
obviously tell that he would much rather
be awkwardly dancing with all those
nerds at homecoming but then Peter sees
his reflection with the spider-man mask
half covering his face and he
understands Starks words finally that he
has to be a hero underneath the suit
also this visual spider-man trapped
under the rubble was another moment
pulled from the comics the amazing
spider-man number 33 now this finale on
Starks cargo plane looks really cool I
really like surprising viewers by
upgrading the planes look with this
cloaking device which is similar to the
son agents of shield now I'll admit that
the CGI spectacle doesn't totally have
the same emotional stakes as the other
scenes and Philip actually goes into why
that might be the case for you and is
review so again go take a look at that
but here's what I'm curious about what's
gonna happen to Avengers tower now
that's stark and happy I've finished
moving out one theory that I hope ends
up happening in some way is that the
tower ends up getting bought by Oscorp
it would be really cool to see this
landmark in the MCU turn into something
more sinister but considering Sony still
owns the rights to spider-man and all of
its associated characters I just don't
know if Marvel will be allowed to do
that anyway after Peter saves tombs on
the beach he watches the authorities
arrive while sitting on top of the
cyclone rollercoasters now that is
another past MCU reference in Captain
America Steve and Bucky reminisce over
riding the cyclone on Coney Island until
Steve threw up anyway moving on you
might have noticed this kid in a tiger
mascot costume running in the background
a few times but of course Tiger is
actually a famous spider-man nickname
it's what Mary Jane calls Peter both and
her first line to him in the comics and
her final line to him in spider-man 2
okay thank you so I feel like seeing
this tiger again here might be
foreshadowing this reveal with Michelle
whose friends call her
MJ yes how very John Robin Blake of you
homecoming now Kevin Feige has actually
explained that this doesn't mean that
Michelle is the same character as Mary
Jane Watson she's a different character
but they're giving her the moniker of MJ
to evoke that dynamic with Peter
remember the cinematic universe is its
own separate universe it can create and
adapt characters and storylines and new
directions as much as a once and not
knowing where they're going is part of
that fun okay then when happy takes
Peter to the New Avengers facility
upstate Peters science punch shirt is
the same shirt that Pepper Potts wore in
Iron Man 3 which may be foreshadowing
when she shows up at the end of this
scene but we got to talk about this new
suit this looks a lot like the iron
spider armor from the comics now the
iron spider suit is what stark designs
for spider-man in the Civil War comics
when he recruits Peter to his side in
the war it's why the colors are the same
red and gold color palette the iron
spider is super high-tech it can do a
ton of stuff but most prominently it has
these three mechanical spider arms
called Waldo's but then in this movie
Peter turns it all down
Antti doesn't do starts press-conference
and both of these are also tied to civil
war because in those comics stark holds
a major press conference alongside
spider-man but that spider-man is way
different he's older at the end of his
career that he actually unmasks himself
at the press conference but the civil
war movie went a very different way they
made Peter Parker younger still a teen
before he really teams up with the
Avengers so that's why we still haven't
really gotten a super advanced iron
spider yet in the movies and why we
don't get this press conference it's
just not time for that yet
instead Stark plans to use the press
conference to announce something else
his engagement to pepper so happy said
that he's been holding on to this ring
since 2008 and oh okay so even though
the first Iron Man movie came out in
2008 all the events are set in 2010 so
is happy saying that stark plan to
propose to pepper since he returned and
that that was actually 2008 or was stark
planning to propose her long before all
that happened does any of this have any
effect on this eight years later time
jump look guys I don't know the dates
and timelines in this movie are just
very confusing and I at the end of it
blame dr. strange so what happens when
you metal but let's move on to our
closing images after declining starts
offered to fulfill his childhood dream
to join The Avengers Peter realizes that
that goal is no longer something he
really needs right now
like after not getting the girl and then
missing out on all these fun teenage
experiences he realizes he doesn't need
to grow up so fast what he needs is to
stay as a teenage hero a friendly
neighborhood spider-man so instead of an
image of Peter and badass iron spider
armor alongside the Avengers we get him
back in his old stark spider-man suit
standing in his bedroom in Queens and
that desire to hold on to his youth
which is the essence of spider-man as a
character as we know him in the comics
peter has ironically grown into a man do
you think Peter should have taken this
new suit
I'll be honest part of me did die when
he didn't just go hell yeah and throw
that thing on and I need your help on
this one
what do you make of this timeline stuff
do you think there's anything to my
theory about Doctor Strange if not what
else could it be
anyway weigh in on all this stuff in the
comments also like this video and share
it and subscribe the new rock stars
because some big things are happening at
this channel so come on board you can
hit me up on twitter directly at EA vas
or follow new rockstars on twitter at
new rock stars for channel updates thank
you for watching
and have I been wearing it Captain
America's shirt this whole time I
thought it was spider-man why didn't
anyone say anything